We should see it differently.
We have also put together new arguments
and then the court can review its own
decision again.
If necessary, the next
higher court of the Higher Regional Court has to
decide on it. Now
we are responsible, but it is not
binding  This
regional court has made a decision in the
other matter, which is why we are continuing the
investigation at the moment
and it will stay that way
until there is another
decision. It should
then actually be determined by
a corresponding binding legal
court decision that  If the
public prosecutor's office
is not locally responsible, we would
of course immediately hand over the investigation to the
responsible public prosecutor's office,
possibly in Saxony-Anhalt,
but until that is the case
we will continue to investigate here without being impressed
Don't make it big at all and just a
question just for understanding because
there are also these other cases against the
accused, but this search
is in connection with the
medimed case, we really know
Portugal are in connection with the
Medley mckenn procedure, that is,
due to certain
We are investigating clues there in Portugal, there is
a major search operation taking place,
which is being carried out by the Portuguese
authorities, but there are also
German officers from the Federal Criminal Police Office
on site who are supporting the whole thing. I
cannot disclose the background at the moment,
so why we are looking there
and what we are specifically looking for  hope to find us there,
that should remain our secret at the moment
then one last
question is not about it but
basically, whenever
things don't happen secretly, quietly and quietly
but without much media interest,
many people
sometimes have the feeling that it is happening  nothing
because you haven't heard anything since that big press conference
two years ago or two and a half years ago,
but something happens to you, there
are other procedures etc. so
maybe they'll say again it's
not that likely because you're
not here every day now  stands and what does
n't you hear in the background what's
happening so it's still being investigated in this
case all the time
probably the actions Portugal
shows that investigations are actually
taking place they are not always as
noisy as they are now it could
n't be avoided completely  We
also decided, as an exception,
to communicate something because it is
taking place in a public place and it
can actually be determined by residents or visitors that what is
happening there is also clear, due to the spatial proximity
with us, that this will
possibly be brought into connection with
this  That's why we
decided to communicate this,
but investigations are constantly taking place.
The statement was three years ago
when we announced that we were
investigating the case. Since then, the investigation has been
ongoing and
since then
all measures of
various kinds have taken place
Interrogations are searches
and other stories that are
urgently not made public because we do
n't think it's necessary at the moment,
it's also because the accused has
n't had access to the files at the moment
and that's why it's not
our job to make it public
to communicate more than the
accused himself, that is also a
requirement of fairness that we
actually hold back and only
act when it is unavoidable and
that is actually the case now because
these measures
are so public that we
wanted to explain it,
great and then  Please let us know as
soon as possible what you
found there. If we find something
and we keep the results
published, then we will
certainly inform you about it,
but we will give ourselves a little time, the
action itself will also
take a while, that is now  not
completed within two hours or so and of
course we'll have to
see if we find something and what we find first, great then thank you very much